have breaking news also on former
president bill clinton he's in the
hospital at uc irvine near los angeles
with a non-coveted related infection his
spokesman says the 75 year old is on the
mend and in good spirits our doctor
david agus has been in contact with mr
clinton's lead doctor and the former
president's team who gave him permission
to discuss his case
dr agus what can you tell us about the
former president's condition right now
well former president clinton flew on a
plane to southern california for a
series of events and landed on tuesday
at the first event he started to feel
light-headed nausea vomiting was brought
to a hospital and at that hospital was
found to have an infection in his blood
and they did a cat scan looked all over
his body and even his brain and the
infection source was found to be the
urine
the bacteria that grew out was called e
coli and it was put on what we call a
broad spectrum antibiotics so several
antibiotics once they identified it as e
coli they're down to one intravenous
antibiotic and today we'll get the
results of what are the sensitivities
that is what a bacteria subset of e coli
it is so hopefully he can go on an oral
antibiotic watch that overnight and then
go home on that or antibiotic for
several weeks of treatment for that
infection in the blood and the bladder
when is he likely to be released
well certainly hope that he can go on an
oral antibiotic today and then go home
over the weekend he's doing dramatically
better
back to his normal sense joking with
staff and back to the former president
clinton that we all know and loved and
so tremendously
happy that there was this recovery and i
think you know hillary was there
yesterday visiting him and i think
things are going much much better so
hopefully over the weekend
all right well good to hear that he is
in good spirits dr aegis thank you